If you are one of those people who is introverted
or camera shy
or has a job
that doesn't allow you to make money from the side,
but you really need to.
Or maybe a family members
that concern themselves with your lives,
if you care about what everyone thinks
but at the same time
you always wanted to be a micro influencer.
Or forget being a micro influencer.
You really like
no homegirl,
I just need an extra 2 G's a month.
Then this is for you.
This is not me selling.
This is me being 100% honest and transparent.
The pages that are going viral right now
all over social media are called faceless
digital marking accounts. Literally,
you can blow up a new page in just a few weeks.
You can get thousands of followers
and these girls are making 5, 10, 15,
20,000 a month.
Um, I started one. Okay,
but this is really good for the girls who are
like camera shy.
Or maybe you just have like
an ex that just keeps tabs on you
and you need to make money for uni kids.
But you wanna go faceless,
this is for you.
Um, the course of course.
The course of course that I've been promoting
teaches you how to do digital marketing
from the ground up.
But the Faceless Bundle gives you stock images
and captions and hooks
and teaches you how to go faceless from the ground up.
So that is what I'm giving away for free with.
For anyone who wants to start digital marketing with me.
And then if you just want the Faceless
Digital Marketing Bundle,
then it's 32% off,
which is a law. Actually,
when you put in my code for my birthday,